Hello everyone, welcome to another tango
technique class at home. I hope you're
all doing fine. Today's class will be
very useful for women because we will
work on different techniques for our
ochos back. But I also recommend that
men do this class as well because all
the ideas that we see today will be also
very useful for men, yeah? Uh
they will be useful anytime that you
need to do a step where you cross your
free leg back. For example, back sacadas
or any step that you do that looks like
an ocho back, okay? So because women use
ochos all the time, yeah, so often, the
class will be very beneficial for them
but for us as well, okay? So there's two
different techniques. The first one is
probably the one that you are most
familiar with because it's the one where
you move your hip first and the rotation
of the hip drives the movement of the
free leg, yeah? The movement of the free
leg is a consequence of the movement of
the hip.
And the second technique is the
opposite. It's where you move your free
leg first and then the movement of the
leg provokes the movement of the hip.
The rotation of the hip is a consequence
of the movement of the leg, yeah? And
using one or the other
will give you very different qualities
for your ochos and also will fit better
different situations. To simplify, I
call the first technique hip first and
the second technique leg first, okay? So
today we will start with our warm-up
with an extra exercise at the end for
our core, which will be very useful for
the work afterwards, and then we will do
a series of exercises where we will use
each one of these two techniques in our
ochos back, okay? So let's start with
the warm-up. Okay, warm-up.
So it will be like always with the extra
exercise at the end. So we start with
feet together, yeah? And just take a few
seconds to relax, breathe deeply, and
feel the weight of your body coming down
and the pressure of the feet on the
floor, yeah? Okay? Legs together as if
you want to press something between your
knees. And then we start with the
shoulder rotations, yeah? So, remember,
don't use the elbows, keep them relaxed.
And make the circle as big as you can in
every direction, yeah? Forward, up,
back, and down, yeah? We do eight
slowly. One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
and eight. Now we do big circles with
both arms. Remember, the elbows should
be always straight, yeah? Don't bend
them. And when you open the arms, move
your hands a bit behind your back so
that you really stretch the chest
muscles, okay? And we do it eight times
as well. One,
two, relax the shoulders,
three, make the circle as big as you
can,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
and eight. Okay. Now we do this one, the
stretch for the
for the torso, for the side, yeah? And
because we have done this a lot, yeah?
When you slide down the the leg to touch
your knee, you should be able by now to
pass the knee, yeah? To touch a little
bit below the knee, okay?
And then we hold the stretch a few
seconds. And then we repeat with the
other arm. So, you make sure that the is
straight. Yeah? Don't have it like this,
half bent, straight. And then try to
pass the knee. Yeah? With this hand try
to pass the knee. And then we hold the
stretch for a while, and then up again.
Okay? And we'll do it four times each
side. So, one
go down,
hold it,
and up.
The other side, one
go down, hold it,
and up. Sorry, it's windy outside.
Two
down, hold it,
and up.
And two
go down, hold it,
and up.
Three
go down, hold it,
and up.
And three
go down, hold it,
and up.
And four
down, hold it,
up,
and four
go down,
hold it,
and up.
Okay, good. Now, we open the legs, we
bend the knees a little bit, and we make
a circle with the arms, and we do
rotations of the torso, left and right.
Now, remember, the hip doesn't move.
Yeah? Don't turn the hip like this. And
the head also doesn't move. Hip and head
forward. And don't move the arms alone.
Yeah? The arms and the chest have to
move together as a block. Yeah? The
hands are always in front of your chest,
because this movement is actually not
done with the arms, but it's done with
the back. Okay? So, we do eight times to
each side twice, eight and eight. Okay?
One and
two
and
three and
four and
five and
six and seven and
eight. Eight more. One and
two and
three and
four and
five and
six and
seven and
eight. Okay. Now, we stretch the knees
and we put our hands behind the head.
Yeah? And then we bend forward until the
back is parallel with the floor.
And then we continue going down letting
our head hang. And then we bounce three
times. One, two, three. Very relaxed.
And then we stretch the back again until
it's parallel with the floor again.
And then we go up.
And that's one repetition. And we do
eight. Okay? Very slowly.
One go down.
Bounce, bounce, bounce
and
up.
Two
and
bounce, bounce, bounce
up.
Three
and
bounce, bounce, bounce
up.
And
four
bounce, bounce, bounce
and
up.
And
five bounce, bounce, bounce
and
up.
And
six
bounce, bounce, bounce
and
up.
And
seven
bounce, bounce, bounce and
up.
And
eight
bounce, bounce, bounce
And
up. Okay?
Good. Now, we close our legs really
tight, including the feet. The feet are
together and parallel. Okay? And then
from here, we bend our knees and we
bounce three times, very relaxed. Yeah?
Be careful that your hip stays straight
when you go down. Yeah? That it doesn't
go back or forward. Yeah? Straight.
Bounce, bounce, bounce. And we stretch
the knees. We go up. We push the floor
with the toes, really strong. We block
the
um
the joint of the foot so that it's
easier to stay up. We make our core
tight. And then we hold it a few
seconds. And then we go down. And then
we bounce again three times. Yeah? So,
we do it eight times. So, bend the
knees. One, bounce, bounce, bounce.
Stretch the knees. Go up. Hold it.
One, two, three. And go down. Okay? Two,
bounce, bounce, bounce.
Go up.
Hold it.
And go down.
Three, bounce, bounce, bounce. Stretch
the knees. Go up. Press the floor. Hold.
And down. Four, bounce, bounce, bounce.
Go up.
Hold it.
Go down.
Five, bounce, bounce, bounce. Go up.
Hold it.
And go down.
Six, bounce, bounce, bounce.
Go up. Push the floor.
And go down. Seven, bounce, bounce,
bounce.
Go up.
Hold it.
And go down. Control, slowly. Yeah?
Bounce, bounce, bounce. The last one,
eight. Go up. Hold it.
And when you go down, don't drop. Yeah?
Just go down slowly. Control. Okay? This
will make your lower leg really strong,
which is great for tango. And the last
exercise is like this. I will show you
from the front and I will be your mirror
because exercise is easy to follow. So,
I don't need to show you from behind.
Yeah?
You will stand on one foot. Now, to
mirror me, you can stand on your right.
Okay?
It's okay.
And the free foot you keep close to the
to the standing foot. Yeah? Together.
Both legs together. And the idea is to
rotate your hip to turn your hip to one
side and to the other to make a small
pivot on the floor. Yeah? Now, in order
to do this, you need to start with a
small movement, a small rotation of the
torso, to initiate the movement with the
torso, and then you can move the hip.
But, try not to do this rotation of the
torso too big. Don't do this.
Yeah? This is not the idea. The idea is
because then you're not working with a
core as much as you should. So, the idea
is to make a movement very small, very
small, and then the big movement is with
the hip. And then to the other side is
the same. Now, you're here, so you do a
small movement with the torso, as small
as you can, and then you rotate your
hip. Okay? So, we will do it eight times
to each side. Okay?
So, stand with one leg, this leg.
And then, let's do it eight times
together.
One
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six and
seven
and eight
and
okay? Now change weight to the other
leg.
Feet together and let's start eight
times with this leg.
One
and
two
three
and
four and
five
and
six and
seven and
eight
and
Okay? Let's do one more time. Eight
times with each leg, yeah? Just because
this exercise will be very useful for
later. So follow me eight times more.
And
one
and
two
three and
four and
five
and
six and
seven and
eight and okay? Change weight and now
let's do the other leg.
One
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six and
seven and
eight and
Okay, great. So we are ready.
Let's go for the first exercise for our
oceans back. Okay, first exercise for
oceans back using the hip first
technique. So I will show you to the
wall.
We will do each exercise twice. First,
we will do it with support on the wall
and then we will do it on our own, okay?
With our own balance. So first
let's use support on the wall. So when
you support yourself on the wall, just
put the fingers, yeah? Don't put the
whole hand. Put the fingers at the
height of the shoulder. Don't put them
too high or too low. Here is fine. It is
the best place, yeah? And then, don't
lean on the wall and don't raise the
elbows like this, yeah? Because then
that's going to give you the the bad a
bad technique, the wrong technique. So,
just put the fingers, yeah? Light
support. Keep the elbows slow and find
your axis, yeah? Because the wall is
just a little help, nothing more, okay?
Now, the idea is you put your weight on
the left and you bend the knee, yeah?
The whole exercise we will do with the
knee flexed, okay? Then, the free foot
is together with the standing leg in
this pretty zero position, pretty zero.
Pretty because it's not parallel, yeah?
It's a bit behind, you see? The heel
goes a bit behind, yeah? This is
prettier. Okay, and then, without moving
the torso, or at least moving it as
little as possible, you turn the hip
away from the wall. And then, you
project the leg and bring it straight.
And then, you close the leg again in
zero, pretty zero, and then turn the hip
to the wall again, yeah? That's why it's
hip first, because first is the hip,
then is the leg. Close the leg, turn the
hip. Hip first,
leg, close leg, hip, okay? Now,
how does this work with the metronome?
Because we will use, as always, our 58
bpm with two beats per bar. One, two.
One, two. So,
the movement of the leg, this one, when
you project the leg, that's supposed to
be the one, the strong beat. One, two.
Leg, yeah? That means that the rotation
of the hip that comes before has to be
on the and, yeah? On the two, on the
previous two.
And one. So, the exercise with the tempo
will be like this.
And one, and
two, and one,
and two, yeah? And one, this is the main
movement.
And two.
Okay? So, we will do it eight times,
first projecting with right, then
projecting with left, and then we will
repeat it again but without using the
wall, okay? So, let's um
do it together eight times. And one last
tip is because the tempo is slow, when
you project the leg, do it slowly. Don't
shoot the leg and keep it there frozen
until the next beat comes. Try to use
the whole time that you have between
beats to move the leg, yeah? So, that
you're always in movement, okay? So,
let's do it together. Weight on the
left,
support light on the wall, and let's do
it eight times.
And
one.
And two.
And three.
And four.
And five.
And six.
And seven.
And
eight.
Okay? Now, eight times projecting with
the left leg. So, weight on the right,
bend the knee, find your axis,
and then eight times
with left.
And one.
And two.
And three.
And four.
And five.
And six.
And seven.
And eight.
Okay? Good. Great. It's very important
that you don't mix the movements, yeah?
Don't project the leg until the hip is
completely rotated, yeah? Don't start to
move the leg
meanwhile you are rotating the hip,
especially now that the tempo is so low,
okay? Good. Now we'll do the same
without the wall.
So,
weight on the left, yeah? And I will use
the embrace of the woman, but if you're
a man doing this class, you can use also
the embrace of the man, yeah? I just do
it like this, yeah? I will do it like
this. It doesn't matter. Okay, let's do
it eight times together without the
wall.
And one.
And
two.
And three.
And
four.
And five.
And six.
And seven.
And eight.
Okay, yeah? Sorry, the floor is humid.
There is humidity and the shoes get a
bit loud. So, I hope it doesn't disturb
you, yeah? Okay, let's do it eight times
with our weight on the right leg.
And one
and
two
and three
and four
and five
and six
and seven
and eight.
Okay?
Great.
So, a few tips for when you do it
without support. First of all, of course
it's hard when you don't have any
support to turn your hips slowly. Yeah?
The leg is no problem. The leg you can
move slowly because that's just moving
the free leg, but the hip, yeah? There
is a strong tendency to move it very
fast. Yeah? So, the trick to be able to
move your hip a bit slower without
support is to
press with your standing leg on the
floor as much as you can. It's like your
your standing leg is a screwdriver,
yeah? That twists and goes deep down
screwing itself into the into the
ground, yeah? Like this.
Woah, yeah? And then you can twist the
hip
a little bit slower.
Yeah? So, bend the knee and press the
floor during the pivot. And then you can
do this rotation with the hip a bit more
control. Okay? So, let's go to the next
exercise. Okay, the next exercise will
be the same as what we did before, but
twice as fast. So, the first thing we
need to do is to put an extra
subdivision on our metronome like this.
One and two and one and two. Yes, so the
and
is an extra subdivision between beats.
Yeah, because we will use now this
double time or half time. I prefer to
call it half time
for our movement. It's going to be like
this.
So
one and two and one and two and one and
two. Yeah, you see it's double as fast,
but the technique is the same. It's hip
first and then leg.
Hip leg leg hip hip leg leg hip hip leg
leg hip, okay? Try not to move the
torso, yeah? Don't do this.
Yeah, don't do this with the with the
shoulders. You are not supposed to be
working with the shoulders. You are
supposed to be working with the core,
yeah? The core is doing this work. The
core and not the shoulders, yeah? This
this part is twisting, okay? So we will
do it the same as before. Now
but double
double amount of times as well. We will
do it 16 times with each leg, okay? 16
times projecting with right then
projecting with left and then 16 times
again with each leg without the wall,
okay? So let's do it first with the
wall, but remember don't lean too much
on it, yeah?
Just use the fingers, yeah? Just the
fingers, very light support.
Okay, 16 times projecting with right
leg.
And one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
One.
Two.
Okay? Now,
we will be projecting with the left.
So, bend the right leg. Yeah? And we're
going to do that 16 times.
And 1
Okay?
Good. Now, without the wall, so now you
really have to push the floor with your
standing leg and use the core. Yeah? 16
times.
And 1
Okay? Now, we will put our weight on the
right and project with the left. 16
times.
And one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight.
Okay.
You see, this is also good for men
because
this is a back sacada, and if you do
this regularly, your back sacadas will
improve a lot. Okay? So, let's go to the
next exercise. Okay, so in this exercise
we will do a full ocho slowly, yeah? So,
the sequence of movements works like
this. First, we support on the wall.
The ocho will be made of four movements.
The first one is the hip, yeah? You
rotate the hip away from the wall. The
second is the projection of the leg,
yeah? But you are still on this axis.
The third is the transfer of weight,
yeah? When you transfer the weight, make
sure that the torso stays straight and
is moving parallel to the floor, yeah?
Don't go down or do anything like this,
parallel to the floor. And the last
movement, the fourth, is closing the
leg, closing the free leg, yeah? Moving
the foot on the floor, yeah? And then
you start again.
Hip, leg, transfer of weight, close.
Rotate the hip, project the free leg,
transfer the weight, and close the free
leg.
Hip, project, transfer, close.
Hip, project, transfer, close. Okay?
Very clean, very separated.
Um for example,
don't mix the projection of the leg with
the transfer of weight. Yeah? Sometimes
it's very tempting, very easy to start
transferring the weight while you are
projecting. Yeah?
And
uh most of the time it will work, but
it's not good technique. Because if you
have to do this fast, like we will do
afterwards, you will always have the
feeling that you are falling into the
step, that this is happening. Boom.
Yeah? You are falling. So, now that you
have time and that you are practicing
without the partner, yeah? Now you can
really make everything very clean. And
then first project completely and then
transfer the weight. Yeah? Two separate
things. Okay. Now, the last thing.
Um how does this work with the
metronome? So, remember that when you
project the leg, yeah? When you do this
movement, that's the one. Yeah? That's
the main beat. One. Yeah? That means
that the hip has to come on the and
before. So, it's and one.
And two. Yeah? So, the four movements
work like this.
And one. And
two.
Hip,
project, transfer, close. And one. And
two.
And one. And two. Yeah?
And as I said before, now that we're
using a slow tempo, try to adjust the
speed, especially of your free leg, so
that you are always in movement. Don't
do the exercise like this. And one. And
two. Yeah? So, No. Try to maintain
movement during all the time.
And, one, and
two. And, one, and
two. Yeah, you see it moves slowly. And,
you connect the movements. You don't mix
them, but you connect them. Yeah, that's
the idea. Okay. So, let's do it first
with support, eight times to each side.
With a metronome.
So, it doesn't matter from which side
you start, but
let's start from the standing leg, the
weight on the left. Yeah? So, we will
project with the right. Okay, eight
times to each side.
And, one.
And,
two.
And, three.
And,
four.
And, four.
And,
five.
And, five.
And, six.
And, seven.
And, eight.
And,
Okay?
You see, you do the whole exercise very
low, yeah? Bending the knees a lot,
yeah? Here. Don't go up, yeah? Stay low,
yeah?
Okay, and one tip, one important tip.
When you do the step, yeah? When you
project the leg, be very careful with
the position of your foot, because you
have another pivot coming. There is a
strong tendency to put this foot looking
inside, yeah? You see? Instead of
outside. This looks bad, but we all do
this because we are preparing the pivot.
So, try to resist that temptation.
Try to put the foot on the floor
and turn the foot outside. You touch the
floor with the with the big toe, yeah?
And the heel of the foot is towards the
inside, yeah? Towards you. Okay? Like
this. And then, you transfer the weight.
And this is much better than this.
Okay? So, be careful with that. So, now
we will do it again without the wall,
yeah? Eight times to each side.
So, get ready. Weight on the left. Bend
the knee. Now, it's very important be
close to the floor. And then, let's
start all together.
And one.
And
two.
And three.
And
four.
And four.
and five
and six
and seven
and eight
and
Okay?
Sorry for the squeaky shoes.
Um,
good. Let's go to the next exercise.
Okay, in this exercise we will do the
full ultra back in half time using the
hip first technique. So, the first thing
we need is to set
um extra subdivision in our metronome,
in our beat. So, it sounds like this.
One and two and one and Yeah, the and is
a subdivision because we will use this.
We will use the subdivision
to move our hip.
The sequence is the same, yeah? You do
hip project, transfer, close. Hip
project, transfer, close. But, now you
do it in half time.
And one and two and one and two and one
and two. But, it's the same technique,
yeah?
Hip project, transfer, close. Hip
project, transfer, close. Hip project,
transfer, close, yeah? Especially now
that we're working faster, don't mix the
projection
with the transfer of weight, yeah?
Because it will look like this.
Boom.
And you will have the feeling you're
falling, yeah? So, try to separate the
movements, yeah? Project, transfer,
yeah? Project, transfer. First project,
then transfer.
And now that the tempo is faster, the
second thing that you have to be careful
with is the foot. Like I said before,
when you step, uh
don't turn the foot to the inside
because you are preparing the next
pivot. No.
When you project, make sure that the
foot, yeah, is turned outside, yeah?
Like this. Touching the floor with the
big toe and with the heel going inside,
yeah? Not like this, like this. Because
this,
apart from the fact that it looks bad,
yeah, it's it gives you a very bad
support when when you put your weight on
this leg. And then you will need this
leg
very fast, you know, immediately, to
catch yourself. So, it's much better
technique to have the foot looking
outside. And then this gives you a very
good support, okay? Then you can do the
pivot, no problem. And then the same
here. Foot outside, yeah? Boom.
Yeah? It's harder to do it when you
dance fast, but try, okay? So, as
before, we will do it 16 times to each
side, first with the wall, and then on
our own, okay?
So,
let's start.
So, get ready. 16 times.
Feet together, only the fingers on the
wall, and put them quite low, yeah?
Don't put them here, put them quite low.
Put your weight on the left, then bend
the knee, and do the whole exercise
really low, yeah? This will help you.
And we project with the right, 16 times.
And one
one
and two
two
and three
three
and four
four
and five
five
and six
six
and seven
seven
and eight
eight
Eight more. One
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
Okay? Good.
Now, let's do the same but without the
wall, yeah?
So, put your weight on the left like we
did before and
wish me luck.
And one
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
Eight more. One.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay?
Um
If you are struggling with this exercise
at this speed, yeah? I give you
uh a few a few survival tips for this
exercise at this speed, yeah? The first
thing, when you are doing pivots
uh
behind you, yeah? There is a strong
tendency to follow with the arms, yeah?
So, when you do the pivot, the arm opens
as well, yeah? And then you have this.
You open the arm. So, that will bring
your axis behind you. You will fall
backwards. So, try to do the pivot, but
keep the arms always in front, yeah?
When you do the pivot, keep the arms in
front. Keep the arms in front. Always in
front, yeah? Because this is always This
is also what will happen when you dance
with a partner who will stay in front of
you. So, you have to keep your arms on
the partner, no matter what you do with
your hips, okay? The second tip,
it really helps to do the whole exercise
low, especially for this technique,
yeah? Just do the whole exercise really
low. Really low. Really low.
And this will help you with balance. And
the third tip,
and this one is the hardest, but it
really helps. This is what I said before
about the free foot, yeah? That you put
it a bit outside. If you manage to put
your foot in this position, the transfer
of weight is much smoother, yeah? It's
much cleaner. And then it gives you more
confidence
to do it fast, yeah? It's all about
putting the free foot in the right
position. If you put it like this,
forget about it.
You will lose the balance, you will lose
the tempo, okay? So, these three tips
are important. Okay, let's go for the
next exercise. Okay, so now we will
repeat all the exercises that we did,
but using the second technique, which is
leg first, yeah? We will start with the
half back or toe slowly. So, how does
this work?
First of all, you won't need to bend the
knee so much anymore, yeah? You can you
can keep your standing leg quite
straight. Not completely straight, yeah?
Not stretched completely, but
comfortably bent, yeah? Definitely not
like this, yeah? Like this okay. The
second thing is that when you start the
exercise, instead of moving the hip, you
will move the leg. How? So, in a circle,
yeah? You will do a circle with the foot
that starts in zero position, then grows
bigger, and then ends by with your leg
crossed behind, yeah? So, the movement
is like this.
From zero, circle, back, yeah? Until you
can't move the leg anymore. When you
reach the limit here, that's when you
use the hip to finish the movement,
yeah? And the movement of the hip will
come from the impulse of the leg. So,
you move the leg and the leg moves the
hip at the end, yeah? That's the idea.
Leg, hip, yeah? You see it's the
opposite of before. Leg, hip. Now, how
will you come back? When you are here,
don't turn the hip to the wall. Instead
of that, move the leg. Yeah, like this.
So, the leg is retracing the circle back
to zero position, yeah? And this circle
you do it with the free leg very
relaxed. Very relaxed, yeah, like this.
So, that this movement generates the
movement of the hip at the end, yeah?
You see, so it's leg, hip. Leg, hip.
Leg, hip. Leg, hip. Yeah?
You see, it's completely different from
the other ocho, and it's very beautiful.
It's a very beautiful alternative
technique, yeah?
Okay, so we will do one leg at a time.
And how does this work with the music?
It's the same
uh the same idea as before,
but now we will change when we move the
hip and when we move the leg. Because
before, if you remember, the hip was the
and, and the leg projecting was the one.
Now it's the opposite.
The leg is the and,
and the hip is the one, yeah? So, it's
like this. And one. And two. And one.
And two. Leg, hip. Leg, hip. Yeah?
Okay?
So, it's the same idea, yeah? The first
movement is always the and, and the
second is the one, but now the leg is
the first movement, not the hip, okay? I
hope that's clear. Anyway, we will do it
together now.
We will use again a simple beat without
subdivisions.
One.
Two. Leg, hip. Leg, hip. Okay?
And we will do it eight times with each
leg, first with support and then without
support. Okay? So, now put the fingers
on the wall low, keep the elbows
relaxed,
weight on the
left leg, and the option will be much
smaller than the previous one with the
hip first. Yeah? But, that's fine.
That's actually a good thing. Okay,
let's do it eight times going with the
right.
And one.
And two.
And three.
And four.
And five.
And six.
And seven.
And eight.
Okay?
Great. Let's do it with the other leg.
Put your weight on the right, and
remember to do the movement with the
free leg very relaxed. Yeah? It's like a
pendulum. Yeah? Because the more relaxed
it is,
the more realistic will be that the
weight of the leg turns your hip at the
end. Yeah? The movement of the hip
should have no force at all. It should
come from the leg. Yeah? That's the
idea.
Okay, let's do it eight times.
And one.
And two.
And three.
And four.
And five.
And six.
and seven
and eight
Okay, yeah? Now let's do it again. Going
with right, but without the wall, yeah?
Okay, get ready. Eight times.
And one
and
two
and three
and four
and five
and six
and seven
and eight
Okay, now with the other leg.
Weight on the right, we open with the
left.
Eight times.
And one
and two
and three
and four
and five
and six
and seven
and eight
And okay.
So, remember to not mix movements, yeah?
Try to fight the temptation to start the
pivot too early. First, you should
really move the leg completely until you
can't anymore and then this movement
will generate the pivot at the end. The
same here. Don't start the pivot too
early. Yeah? Move the leg until you
can't anymore and then this movement
generates the pivot at the end. Okay?
One last thing, if you're a man and
you're doing this exercise, you might be
wondering
why is this useful for me? When am I
going to use this?
And the answer is that yes, it is useful
because for example,
if you're doing a natural back to do a
back sacada, yeah? That would be the hip
first technique, hip leg and then you go
to the back sacada. You might not want
to do a back sacada with this movement.
You might want instead to catch the foot
of the woman, yeah? So when you do a
back sacada, as you know, your foot has
to go in between the feet of the woman,
yeah? But when you want to catch her
foot, your foot has to come from the
outside and then catch the one of the
feet of the woman. So the movement is
different. It's leg first, leg and hip,
yeah? You see, back sacada is hip first,
hip leg back sacada.
Catch her foot is the opposite. It's leg
hip catch her foot. You see? So
uh this is to answer the question of why
men uh benefit from learning technique
that usually belongs to women. I believe
that there are many principles of
technique that apply to both in the same
way and that even if it doesn't look
like, as a man, you can benefit from a
lot of the technique that the woman
needs for her dancing. Yeah, there are
many ideas that are
unisex, yeah? Of course, um
there are movements that belong to the
man and movements that belong to the
woman. Of course, there are movements
that look better on a woman and
movements that look better on a man, but
we are talking about the technique here,
the technique. And the technique is the
same for both, okay? Good. Sorry for the
ranting. Let's go to the next exercise.
Okay, in this exercise we will do the
same that we did before, but in half
time. So, the first thing we need is to
set an extra subdivision in our
metronome because we will use it for the
leg now, yeah?
And one and two and one and two. So, how
the exercise works now
is the same.
You start with your weight on the left
and then you move the leg in order to
move the hip, but now it's in half time.
It's like this.
Leg, hip, leg, hip, leg, hip, leg, hip,
leg, hip, yeah? So, it's very important
that you really relax the leg, yeah?
Relax it completely and let the swing of
the leg move your hip, yeah? Don't worry
about your hip at all. You have to worry
about your leg.
Yeah?
One. Especially when you're here,
don't turn the hip. Move the leg, yeah?
Relax the leg and let this movement
bring your hip to the wall, okay? So, we
will do it again as before, eight times
with each leg, first with the wall and
then without the wall, okay? So, put
your fingers on the wall, weight on the
left, and we go with the right. 16 times
because you are working in half time.
And one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
One.
Yeah?
You might feel strange with this
technique because you are uh used to
respond with a hip first, but this is
all about responding with the leg. Yeah?
This is a natural way you really go with
the leg. Okay? So, let's do it with the
other leg. Yeah? Weight on the right and
we go with the left 16 times.
And 1
Okay?
One thing, if because now you are
working faster,
if your foot flies a little bit, yeah?
So, it leaves the floor a little bit
here,
yeah? On this
part of the movement, also here, don't
worry about it. Yeah? Let it fly a
little bit. Of course, don't lift it too
much. Yeah? But, just allow it to leave
the floor a little bit because of the
natural impulse of the leg. Yeah? This
is really not wrong. This will look good
later. Okay? So, now let's do it again
without the wall. Yeah? So, put your
weight on the left and we go with the
right 16
And really, worry only about your leg.
Don't worry too much about the hip,
okay?
And
and one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
Okay? Remember the tip to keep the arms
forward while your hip opens, yeah?
Don't follow the hip with the arm, okay?
Let's do it
now with the other leg, weight on the
right.
16 times going with the left.
Okay.
And one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
Okay.
Great.
Let's go to the next exercise. Okay, so
in this exercise we will do the full
ocho slowly with leg first, yeah? So,
how does this work?
It's like this.
The first movement, you stand on one
leg, and the first movement is the leg,
yeah? Like we did before. So, leg, hip.
That's the first movement. After the
hip, then comes the transfer of weight.
Yeah? We will use one bit only for the
transfer of weight. And the last
movement, the fourth movement, is
closing the foot. Yeah? So, it's
leg, hip, transfer, close. Leg, hip,
transfer, close. Okay? Now, let's look
at what happens at the end of the of the
combination. Look. Leg, hip, transfer,
close. Now, you want to do the next
ocho. Yeah? Your But your hip is looking
in this direction. Yeah? So, parallel
with the wall. That way. But now you
want to do the next ocho using the leg
first.
So, how do you do that? Well, first,
when you close the foot, don't close on
zero position. Yeah? On a tight zero
position. This technique doesn't mean
that. Yeah? What you do is that you move
your foot in a straight line. Yeah?
Parallel to the wall like this. Yeah?
Without closing on zero. And this is
between you and the partner. The leg is
moving between you and the partner. So,
don't worry because you won't touch him.
Yeah?
And then, when the foot is more or less
here, yeah? That's when you move the leg
around the standing leg in a circle.
Wow.
And this movement is what turns your
hip. Yeah? So, you transfer the weight.
You close the leg, but you don't go on
zero position. You just keep going. And
then you move the leg around the
standing leg, and then you give it a bit
of swing so that it takes the hip. Yeah?
One. Pa.
That's the idea. Yeah? Now, with the
metronome, it works exactly like before.
The leg, which is the first movement,
has to be on the and. And then the hip
will be the one.
And one.
Two is the transfer of weight.
And three is closing your free foot.
Three. Yeah?
And one.
Two, three. And one. Two. Three. Leg,
hip, transfer, close. Leg, hip.
Transfer, close. Leg, hip. Transfer,
close. And so on. Yeah? Okay, so like
before, let's do it eight times with
each uh to each side. Yeah? First with
the wall and then without the wall.
Okay?
So, let's do it together.
With a slow
tempo.
Just the fingers. Yeah? Low and with
elbows relaxed. Put your weight on the
left and we go with the right.
And one.
And
one.
two.
And two.
And three.
And four.
And five.
And six.
And seven.
And eight.
Okay?
Good. Now, let's do it without the wall.
And one.
And two.
And three.
And four.
And five.
And six.
And seven.
And eight.
And
Okay?
So, remember the tips. When you are
throwing the leg back, don't let the arm
open, yeah? Keep the arm always forward,
no matter how far your hip goes, yeah?
When you step,
avoid this, yeah? Step with the big
If you feel your your little toes on the
floor, that's wrong. You have to feel
your big toe on the floor.
Yeah?
Those are the tips. Okay, let's go to
the next exercise. Okay, in the last
exercise we will do the full back ocho
with leg first fast. So, the first thing
we need to do is to set another
subdivision in our metronome.
And one and two and one because on the
and this extra subdivision we will be
moving our leg. Yeah? And
the technique is the same as before.
It's just faster. Yeah? So, it's leg,
hip, and then transfer of weight. Yeah?
First movement is leg. Second movement
is hip. Third movement is transfer of
weight. Fourth movement is closing the
foot. And from here you use the leg
again. Yeah? Leg, hip, transfer, close.
Leg, hip, transfer, close. Leg, hip,
transfer, close. Leg, hip, transfer,
close.
Okay? So, as before we will do it 16
times because now we are working faster
with the wall and then 16 times without
the wall. Okay?
So, let's go for it.
Remember to relax the leg and to really
not worry about your hip. Let the whole
ocho work from the leg. From the leg.
That's the most important idea. Okay?
Let's go. Weight on the left and we
start with the right 16 times.
And one
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
Eight more. One.
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
Okay? Great. Now we do it without the
wall. And remember, the most important
thing here is to relax your leg. And
when you change weight, make sure that
you touch the floor with the big toe,
and that your foot is turned outside,
yeah? I will never repeat this enough,
yeah? Because it's very important, and
everybody makes this mistake. So,
do it like this, yeah? It takes a bit
more effort, but then the transfer of
weight is smoother because this foot can
support you really well when it's in
this position, okay? So, let's do it
without the wall.
Six times.
And one
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
Seven.
Eight.
Eight. Eight more.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay.
A bit of extra work there.
Anyway, it's good for you.
Good. So, that was it. Back ochos with
hip first and with leg first. And
remember, ah, important.
Um, so, as a woman,
how do you know when to use which one?
So, this is connected to the kind of
embrace that you have and the style of
dancing of the man. For example, the man
can lead you back ochos in two ways.
Basically, he can lead your pivot before
the step for the back ocho, or he can
just go himself without almost leaving
any pivot. So,
when he leads the pivot, usually the man
leads the pivot, goes low, and does a
big step. Yeah? It's this way of leading
the ocho. Yeah? I lead the pivot,
I go low, and I do a big step.
Yeah?
If I do this with you, yeah, you have to
use the hip first technique. Hip first.
This is the ocho
that fits with this lead, where the man
goes low and leads the pivot. Okay?
And usually this ocho is very wide.
Yeah? But I could also lead the pivot
differently. For example, the ocho back
differently. I don't lead the pivot so
much or almost nothing at all and I
don't go down and my step is not so big.
It's It's small. So it's more like this.
Yeah? If I do this with you,
yeah, this way of leading
This goes very well with the ocho with
leg first. Yeah? Leg first. This is the
ocho. You see, you are more up.
Your hip moves at the end.
And you start the movement from the leg.
So usually this ocho you would also do
in close embrace. Yeah? You are in close
embrace and you move the leg first.
Yeah?
This looks really beautiful. For the
other ocho, you are in open embrace.
Yeah? And you are moving the hip first
and then you go like this. Yeah? So you
see these two ochos are completely
different. And they give very, very
different feelings and and also they
look very different. But they are both
very beautiful. The first one with leg
first is more intimate. It's softer. It
looks very elegant. The second with hip
first is much bigger. It's more
spectacular. It's more dynamic. Yeah?
Okay. And for the man, remember, you can
also use the same technique. If you use
hip first, you're doing a back sacada to
the woman. For example, if you're using
leg first, you're catching her foot,
yeah? In order to do a gancho or a
pasada or whatever you want, okay? So, I
hope you enjoyed this class
and in the next video we will do the
same thing but with ochos forward, which
is very interesting. Okay, see you
there.